here on the left is a spinning ascii
doughnut and on the right is a doughnut
shaped c code by Andy Sloane that
generates it now with syntax
highlighting now I recommend you check
out Andy's blog post on the mathematics
behind a flying spinning torus aka donut
the link to the post is in the
description the basic steps are create a
circle then create a torus by rotating
the circle about the y-axis then using
rotation matrices spin a doughnut around
the x and z axes finally project the
doughnut on to the 2d screen adding
illumination by calculating the surface
normal after picking a particular light
source the cool thing is because this is
a ski world there's different characters
associated with different levels of
luminance we can go back to the DfE
skate a version of the code that I
generated adding a microsecond sleep
function to aid in the animation
compiling and running the code we'll get
our spinning donut there's a lot of
parameters that you can control with
this donut including the field of view
and the distance of the donut from the
viewer I spend at least an hour every
day learning and exploring outside my
main line of work so I thought it'd be
cool to start throwing together quick
little videos about things that I find
beautiful whether they're basic or
advanced in the world of machine
learning math computer science
programming psychology whatever even
biology physics history and philosophy
so hope this is a value fun and
something you would enjoy
you